oh we have a voicemail number that
number is 2192 david p here's a really
instructive question from a viewer take
a look at this
yeah david you describe yourself as a
left winger right
but seems like you're a pretty big
supporter of capitalism
how do you reconcile that
yeah
well listen that this this goes to some
significant confusion
um most left wingers
are not socialists this is just it's an
empirical reality
uh
most
many left-wingers like me
support socialization of some elements
of society in the economy i want to take
health care outside of the capitalist
system i want to take education outside
of that there are arguments for
with some aspects of housing but not all
taking it outside of just supply and
demand in markets but most left-wingers
are not actually socialists even in
countries like my birth country of
argentina with big socialist traditions
most of the left-wingers are not
actually socialists so there's no
conflict i'm a social democrat
in the style
of some blend of northern european
countries i support a much much more
regulated and controlled version of
capitalism whose main priority is let's
use the fruits of that regulated
capitalism to set a much higher floor
for everybody for the betterment of all
let's also set some kind of ceiling
above which we really are collecting a
lot of taxes for the betterment of
society it's called social democracy but
i don't need
uh
i'm fine with
markets dictating resource allocation
for
consumer electronics
vehicles
products of different kinds i'm okay
with that i think it's okay i think if
you build something
um
and it's a company and it's yours and
you built it i don't think that should
be taken away from you however we
recognize that you built it based on
utility infrastructure established by
the government and through taxation
protection for intellectual property
established by the government presumably
with employees many of whom went to
public schools which is paid for by
through tax right when we recognize well
yeah you you organized the structure and
you built it and so you do deserve many
of the fruits of that labor it was also
built on the backs of all sorts of
government infrastructure and tax
dollars etc etc so that's why we have to
cycle back a portion of it into the
betterment of society that's
fundamentally social democracy
it is a left-wing perspective i would
argue it's the most successful
most successful version of progressive
ideology globally over the last 150
years okay so that's my perspective
we've got a great bonus show for you
today uh absolutely insane travel chaos
and it's not just omicron causing it we
will talk about hillary clinton's
interesting 2024 prediction we'll talk
about how on earth do schools reopen
with omicron spreading so wildly uh and
much more all of those stories on
today's bonus show sign up at
joinpakman.com
and you can use the coupon code wow 22.
and when you type it in you have to you
have to say wow
22.
it saves you big you get access to the
bonus show you join the ranks of
membership for what will be a really
important election year i'll see you
then